hello everyone we have a very exciting
matchup here it's from the under-16
Youth Chess Olympiad played in India
it's played from 10th to 19th of
December and this is round five and this
was a very anticipated matchup like I
said I'm a international 12 year old
international master Ramesh Babu pragma
anda of India is playing with the white
pieces against 14 year old international
master from Iran ali reza firoozeh so
it's it's quite a quite a matchup and
Prabhu has the white pieces in the
previous two games he had the white
pieces he opened up with Knight to f3 in
this game he chose to go for a 4 so
let's see this game if you Rosia plays
c5 the sicilian defence we had Knight to
f3 Knight to c6 d4c capture son d4
Knight captures and a 6 the time-honored
variation Knight to c3 by Prabhu Queen
c7 I would have the bastard call
variation Bishop to e2 now a six Prague
of castles and Knight to f6 Bishop to e3
Bishop to e7
now f4 and we have D six transposing
into the ship inning and variation a for
now probably doesn't want to allow
heroes yet to push b5 so he stops it
with a four we have castles King to h1
so it's a useful move McHale towel once
said that whenever you Castle kingside
and push the f4 pawn make sure you play
King to h1 especially in opening such as
the Sicilian were black moved his C pawn
than ideas I mean he has a queen and a
dark square bishop you can always get
some some kind of a discovered check
rook to e8 we have Bishop to f3 now rook
to b8
preparing to put b5 in some in some
variations and also getting the rock out
of a eggs because the bishop from f3 is
slicing all the way there so g4 probably
goes for the attack on the King side and
we have a Knight to d7 preparing to ship
the night to c5 and also now white can
push g5
which tempo so g5 nevertheless and it's
it's definitely a good moment to
consider a move like f5 on the next move
and Queen to d8 by if eros are stopping
this now if you play something like f5
you simply Bishop captures on g5 the
Queen and the eight is supporting the
bishop so after Queen to d8 Queen to e2
and this might be might be a weird
choice to put a queen on e too but I
don't know it's it's hard to find a
better move for white here crowd I don't
know me and maybe push h4 but who knows
Queen to d2 night capture Sundy for now
Bishop captures and E 5 Bishop to e3 he
captures on f4 Bishop captures on f4 and
now Knight to c5 and here Prager pushes
h4 and this is what I mean was it really
necessary to play Queen to e2 if after a
variation like this now you can have a
push h4 it's a probably some very very
very advanced
you know advanced just being played here
Bishop to e6 now Queen to d2 and again
this is what I mean not Queen comes to D
- Quinta c8 King to h2 and now Knight to
d7 Knight d5 and Knight to e5 attacking
the bishop on f3 Bishop back to G 2 and
now Bishop to f8 and here it's kind of a
critical moment in the position progress
still has this these backward pawns b2
and c2 and he decides to play c3 and
this this wasn't the best idea
and furiosa will will take advantage of
this greatly a better idea was something
like b3 not allowing the Queen to jump
to c4 but now for example Queen to c5
isn't is isn't doing much since after c4
everything is okay everything is okay
for white but after c3 fedosya
immediately jumps with the Queen to see
for not allowing any b3 ideas now
now you have to get rid of the Queen on
c4 it's it's too powerful of a square
for a queen
so 933 keeping the Queen back and now
paint the c5 but now the wall the Queen
isn't c5 it's it's very different a five
by Provo and we have Queen to b5 Bishop
to g3 now rugby to c8 King to h1 and
night to d3
now harassing that B to pawn Prague
decides to go for b4 and it's it's
pretty clear now that this C c3 pawn
will become a permanent target for the
rest of the game Knight to e5 preventing
the pawn from being pushed forward
Knight to f5 now we have Queen to c6
rook F 2 c1 Queen to c7 night to d4
Bishop to c4 now and Knight to f5 g6
Knights the e3 attacking the bishop and
the bishop to g7 now the bishop will
also support the attack on the c3 pawn
Knight captures on c4 Knight captures on
c4 and Queen to f2 knight back to e5 I
would have Queen to e2 now and Queen to
d7 rook to a3 and disrupt a3 it's one
it's the one move I don't understand in
the game I mean I don't understand a lot
of moves but I I can get a general idea
of why they were played but this rock a3
I have no idea why rocketry was played
it's I mean see c3 pawn is a weakness of
course you want to at some point double
up on the C file like Roxy - and then
rook a to c1 or rook a to and then rock
from a 2 to C to doubling up like that
but this rook to a3 is it's a weird move
here if heroes have played Queen 3 6 but
he could have taken advantage of this
rook to a3 move by playing d5 trying to
open up this efile for the rook and
after something like rook to d1 now
Knight to c4 jumping to c4 which temple
taking advantage of this rook on a 3 and
after rook - eh - Queen
to e6 now pinning the spawn and black is
threatening to capture it it's it's a
pure pawn I mean a very nice clean
central pawn and if you play something
like rookie actor son b5 this doesn't
work
black will not capture the rook but
instead playing Knights to e3 attacking
your rook and if you capture the night
with the Queen then Queen captures rook
and rook captures Queen and then it's
winning for black so after the rook
moves not simply Knight captures on g2
King characters and g2 and Bishop
captures on c3 and now the white king
the white king is wide open and it's
it's probably a winning position for
black but okay after rook to a3 Queen to
e6 was played rook to c2 now rook to c7
now fedosya is preparing to double up on
the C file himself and now Prager plays
rook back to a-1 so that's why I really
don't understand the rock a3 move okay
rook eat the see a doubling up and now
probably plays rook a to C one that we
got from the C file as well h6 and here
it's a well black is black is already
better here but probably a move to
consider with something like Bishop to
Bishop to f4 so if H captures Bishop can
capture but here black would simply push
h5 and now black black is controlling
the king side and it's only white that
will that will be attacked so white will
have two weaknesses the c3 pawn and the
the open King on the Kings side but
after eight six primer played Queen to
f1 and this allowed H captures on g5 h
capture son g5 and now Queen to g4 with
tempo attacking the bishop on g3 and
here Prague played Bishop to f4 or
although a slightly a slightly better
maneuver would be Queen to f4 but after
Queen to h5 check Queen blocks Queen
captures Bishop captures Knight 2 D 3
and again this is this is quite winning
for black your rook is attacked on c1 if
the rook for example rook here then you
simply lose the c3 pawn and if you play
rook to d1 to attack the knight then
simply Knight captures and before you
can't recapture because you'll lose the
rook and c2 but after Queen to g4 Prager
played Bishop to f4 Knights the d3 was
played and it's a pretty pretty wild
position if you capture the night then
Queen captures Bishop with but this is
probably the best thing to do for white
here Bishop to d6 capturing was played
by Prague Oh
although Queen captures which Queen
captures on f4 and it would be it would
be slightly better but still black life
is much better here you still have this
annoying threat on c3 this pawn is a
real weakness ideas like Bishop e5 are
coming fall by Queen h2 so not a
pleasant position I mean like probably
definitely winning for for furiosa
so after 93 Prague tried Bishop captures
on d6 but here we have Queen to h4 check
Bishop to h3 and now Knight captures on
c1 Bishop captures on c7 rook captures
rook captures and now rook captures on
c3 rook captures Bishop captures and
here you can see the problem for now the
material is equal but fedosya has a dark
square bishop
Prague has a light square bishop and
Prague has three pawns that can't be
moved on dark squares and these points
will be extremely easy targets so Queen
to a3 attacking the bishop bishop
captures nothing really you can do about
this and probably was for the Queen to
g4 hoping maybe maybe you know it's it's
an opposite Bishop endgame maybe he did
maybe he could create some drawing
chances but the Queen captures Bishop
captures and now Bishop captures another
pawn okay Braco has a bishop to c8 he
will win at least one pawn bishop to d8
and a bishop characters and a5
so it's a pawn up in an opposite colored
Bishop endgame but
the two points are separated this point
is on the dark square it will be
captured and next move so Bishop c6
Bishop captures on g5 now it's two pawns
up and it's this is simply unplayable
King G - Bishop to f4 King f3 Bishop to
e5 Bishop to a for King to f8 king - III
and now g5 and in this position the
Indian International Master Ramesh Babu
pragma Nanda resigned the game so yeah a
great game for early rise of Arusha and
probably had an amazing start to the
tournament out of the first three games
he won two games and drew one game but
in round 4 and in round five he lost so
I always always not hard to see young
probably lose a game since you know
everyone is cheering for him but yeah
you know you can't win every game and
he's up against a high rated opponent
who is also considered to be a prodigy
and home one day contender for the title
but yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it in the description below I
will put a link where you can watch a
live footage from this game I was shot
by chess base India so very interesting
I think it's about 10 minutes long I can
watch the first twelve or thirteen moves
play the played live and also I will put
a link in the description below where
you can watch all it is a few Rosia play
play blitz against Hikaru Nakamura very
very exciting so yeah I would like to
thank selling vaya for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here think all for watching and I
will see you soon